und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend lassen Sie uns mit einem Gedicht
beginnen
Luftalarm im ganzen Land als würden alle
gleichzeitig zur Erschießung geführt
dabei nur auf einen gezielt meistens auf
den am Rande heute ist das nicht du
Entwarnung
die Schriftstellerin Victoria armelinat
trifft damit exakt das was viele ihre
Landsleute in der Ukraine fühlen jeden
Tag wieder
jetzt war Viktoria amelina selbst die am
Rande auf die gezielt wird sie wurde nur
37 Jahre alt sie starb an den Folgen
einer russischen raketenattacke Ende
Juni auf ein Restaurant in grammatosk in
dem sie mit Freunden saß
die Menschen in der Ukraine trauern in
diesen Tagen wieder besonders viel ihre
Gegenoffensive läuft aber sie kommt kaum
voran und sie fordert hohe Verluste und
daran ändert offenbar auch das Chaos
innerhalb der russischen Armeeführung
nichts das während des kurzen
wagneraufstands zu Tage trat russland
hat sich verbarrikadiert mit zahllosen
Minen und verheerenden Folgen für alle
die dadurch wollen Dominik lesmeister
das Dorf wie am pill in der Region
Donezk viel haben Sie hier durchgemacht
erst erobert von den Russen dann
zurückerobert von der Ukraine ein Team
des niederländischen Fernsehens ist
unterwegs mit einer ukrainischen Einheit
die jetzt den Ort wieder verteidigen
muss vor russischen Angriffen
derzeit kommt es in der Nähe von ihrem
Pilze heftigen Kämpfen sie versuchen
unsere Verteidigung zu durchbrechen sie
scheitern weil wir Gräben ausheben
auch die Ukraine gegen Offensive kommt
trotz westlicher Waffen und Gerät nur
mühsam voran in den vergangenen Wochen
hat Kiews Militär nach eigenen Angaben
insgesamt eine Fläche von 37
Quadratkilometer zurückerobert das
entspricht knapp einem Drittel der
Fläche der Nordsee Insel Sylt
in der vergangenen Woche wurde zum
Beispiel im Osten in der Richtung
bachmut die Position unserer Truppen
verbessert das bisher befreite Gebiet um
9 Quadratkilometer vergrößert
eine Offensive mit Hindernissen die
ukrainischen Truppen haben es mit
gestaffelten Verteidigungslinien der
Russen zu tun zuerst kommen Minenfelder
die einen Angriff verschweren sogenannte
Drachenzähne aus Beton verhindern ein
schnelles durchkommen von Panzern
schützen Gräben bieten Schutz für
russische Soldaten Panzergräben
vervollständigen die Verteidigungslinien
mit Artillerie und Raketenwerfern
diese Bilder des russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums von Anfang
Juni sollen unter anderem zerstörte
Leopard Panzer zeigen überprüfen lässt
sich das nicht der russische
Verteidigungsminister sieht die Ziele
der Ukraine nicht erreicht
allein in den Regionen südtiron jetzt
saporisia und dann jetzt wo ukrainische
Verbände erfolglose Angriffe durchführen
zerstörten Gruppen der russischen
Streitkräfte 15 Flugzeuge drei
Hubschrauber 920 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
darunter 16 Leopard Panzer
wir müssen also danke für Leopard zahlen
und Aussagen die sich nicht überprüfen
lassen die Ukraine äußert sich nicht zu
Verlusten doch die Luft Überlegenheit
der russischen Truppen erschwere die
Offensive heißt es der Ukraine fehlen
Kampfflugzeuge wie die F16 die bisher
vom Westen nicht geliefert wurde den
Erfolg der Offensive in Frage zu stellen
sei aber zu früh sagen Militärs ich habe
gesagt dass dies sechs acht zehn Wochen
dauern wird es wird sehr schwierig
werden sehr lange dauern sehr sehr
blutig und darüber sollte sich niemand
Illusionen machen die Ukraine kämpft um
ihr Leben es geht langsamer voran als
erwartet für die Ukraine und die Sorge
ist groß dass es zu einem langen
abnutzungskrieg kommt
sönke-netzel ist bei uns erst
Militärhistoriker an der Uni Potsdam
Herr Professor willkommen zurück im
heute schon mal guten Abend
guten Abend ja da war es gerade wieder
abnutzungskrieg dieses furchtbare Wort
wie Verfahren ist denn die Situation aus
ihrer Sicht
ja wir sehen seit etwa drei Wochen
Angriffe der Ukraine auf die russischen
Stellung und die Ukraine versuchen
eigentlich alles was so möglich ist sie
sind ein ganz verschiedenen Taktiken
vorgegangen sie haben es mit gepanzerten
Kräften versucht er mit Infanterie an
der ganzen Frontbreite von saporoshje
bis nach bachmut aber bislang können
sich die Ukraine nicht wirklich
durchsetzen wir haben es auch in ihrem
weiteren gehört sie konnten einiges
Gebiet zurückerobern aber ein
entscheidender Durchbruch also eine
weiche Stelle du möchtest mal sagen
haben sie bislang nicht gefunden sie
haben aber bislang auch nicht die Masse
ihrer Kräfte eingesetzt also es gibt
noch Garden die gar nicht im Kampf
fahren wir haben deutsche Schützenpanzer
Marder noch nicht im Kampf gesehen ähm
aber es dauert schon drei Wochen und
noch ist eigentlich nicht klar wie die
Ukraine in einen wirklichen zählbaren
politisch verwertbaren Erfolg erzielen
wollen die westlichen Waffen auf Seite
der Ukraine waren offensichtlich bislang
nicht dieser sogenannte gamechanger wie
von manchen ja gedacht
nein das waren sie nicht jetzt war von
vornherein nicht zu erwarten dass man
mit 18 Leopards zwei A6 jetzt den Krieg
gewinnt aber die westlichen Waffen haben
auch technische Probleme gezeigt also
die sind auch zum Teil für ganz andere
Szenarien gebaut worden sie müssen zum
Teil nachgerüstet werden und man hat
auch gesehen dass die Russen zum
Beispiel die russischen
Kampfhubschrauber auch die russischen
Minen die sie auch in ihrem Beitrag
erwähnt haben ein erhebliches Problem
darstellen und das auch die westlichen
Waffen auch die ganz modernen westlichen
Waffen also da wachsen die Bäume nicht
in den Himmel und ähm in der Tat ist es
kein Game changer und die große Frage
ist jetzt schon von außen drauf wir
wissen natürlich auch nicht alles wie es
jetzt weitergehen soll ja was braucht
denn die Ukraine um tatsächlich Erfolge
zu erzählen jetzt am nötigsten
auch das ist in ihrem Beitrag schon
erwähnt worden ich glaube das ist vor
allen Dingen ein abnutzungskrieg also
und die Ukraine braucht letztlich
momentan mehr Personal ich glaube dass
das in diese Richtung gehen wird dass
die Ukraine mehr mobilisieren werden
dass sie die Listen von unabhängig
unabkömmlich gestellten Personen
reduzieren werden um noch mal mehr
Soldaten zu rekrutieren die dann
wiederum im Westen auch unter anderem in
Deutschland ausgebildet werden müssen
und ausgerüstet werden müssen wir sind
in einer Phase in der die Russen
scheinbar nicht geschwächt sind durch
die Vorgänge jetzt in der letzten Tage
und in der nach wie vor die Strategie
der Russen gilt der Ukraine ihren Krieg
aufzuzwingen das heißt ein langen
abnutzungskrieg in dem die Russen auch
darauf setzen dass im Westen der Ruf
nach Frieden größer wird und das ähm die
Unterstützung im Westen schwinden wird
genauso wie die Russen daraus setzen das
vielleicht auch die Unterstützung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung für diesen
Krieg finden wird ja und in der Tat kann
man ja mittlerweile selbst in der
Ukraine Menschen treffen die nach dem
Sinn des Ganzen Fragen zumal wenn sie
aktuell Brüder Männer Väter an der Front
haben und merken wie unfassbar
gefährlich das ist für diese Menschen wo
sehen Sie denn aktuell den militärischen
Nutzen dieser Offensive
das Problem ist dass wir natürlich nicht
in den in die Pläne des ukrainischen
Generalstabs schauen können und wir
sollten uns auch sagen immer allen
Überlegungen enthalten wie man es
vielleicht irgendwie besser machen
könnte das können wir schlicht nicht
beurteilen wir wissen nicht was das
Kalkül der Ukraine ist ob sie weiter
versuchen anzugreifen um darauf zu
hoffen doch eine Schwachstelle zu finden
um dann eben mit Macht durchzubrechen
wie weit ist das was jetzt wir gesehen
haben auch ein wichtiges politisches
Signal für den NATO-Gipfel um dort noch
mehr Druck aufzubauen seht her wenn wir
ein bessere Waffen mehr Waffen hätten
auch F 16 auf Flugzeuge könnten wir mehr
erreichen das wissen wir alles nicht
aber wir müssen uns immer sagen und das
haben wir schon lange gesagt wird sagen
Analysten das ist nicht ein Krieg der
jetzt mit achten der Lieferung von 18
Leopard Panzern vorbei ist und dann
kommen wir uns wieder der Wärmepumpe
oder anderen Problemen zu wenden sondern
es ist ein langer Krieg und alle Zeichen
stehen auch auf ein langen Krieg wir
alle wünschen uns natürlich einen
Frieden und es gibt ja auch allerlei
diplomatische Initiativen es gibt eine
Reise Diplomatie in die brix-staaten und
das wird auch dazu dienen Druck
aufzuüben Einfluss auszuüben auf
Russland aber momentan muss ich sagen
sieht alles eher Richtung ich sage mal
das Schlagwort totaler Krieg aus im
Sinne von totaler Krieg im Sinne von
Mobilisierung im Sinne von meeressourcen
im Sinne von ein längerer Konflikt jetzt
haben sie das Wort zufrieden gerade
selber gesagt Professor Neitzel wenn der
Krieg eine entscheidende Lösung jetzt
erstmal nicht bringen wird müssen wir
dann nicht viel viel stärker darauf
gucken wie ein Weg zum Frieden aussehen
könnte
ich glaube das ist schon gemacht wird
das wird nur anders gemacht als jetzt
unten beide Diskussionen über über
Waffenlieferungen und dergleichen denn
diese diplomatischen auslotungen hinter
den Kulissen passieren natürlich nicht
öffentlich und der russische Botschaft
deutsche Botschafter in Russland oder
einen Staatssekretär wird jetzt kaum im
heute journal über die Deutschen
friedenspläne in seinem berichten
sondern es ist eher so ein ganz ein
ausloten was ist möglich und ich glaube
das auch man nicht sieht dass irgendwie
eine Bereitschaft auf beiden Seiten ist
die nicht zu erkennen ich sehe nicht
dass hier von deinen Plänen ähm
runterkommt sagen das Land zu befreien
ich sehe nicht das Moskau von den Pläne
runterkommt die den Staat Ukraine zu
zerschlagen darum geht es ja eigentlich
und in dieser Lager kann eigentlich der
Westen der ja auch Partei ist der nicht
neutral ist nur versuchen eigentlich
überbande über über Dritte über Indien
z.B auch ja China der Einfluss ist
begrenzt da dazwischen Druck auszuüben
um es vielleicht zu einer
Verhandlungslösung kommen zu lassen ich
glaube das gemacht wird das Problem ist
nur dass wir davon nicht viel erfahren
nicht viel erfahren können weil es ja
genau das Wesen einer sage mal geheimen
diplomatie ist dass man
davon nicht viel weiß ich glaube dass
das gemacht wird dass die
Bundesregierung auch beide Seiten
verfolgt einerseits die
Waffenlieferungen hier ist ja auch
Urlaub Scholz im Wort und auf der
anderen Seite der Versuch zumindest
auszuloten wohin es gehen könnte sagt
Professor sein Kanal zur
Militärhistoriker an der Uni Potsdam
Herr Professor vielen Dank
sehr gerne
dann gucken wir nach vorne jetzt auf das
was nicht nur den Opfern des russischen
Krieges gegen die Ukraine einmal Trost
spenden soll und Gewissheit Verbrechen
werden nicht ungeahndet bleiben sondern
auch ein Zeichen setzen soll für die
Welt die juristische Aufarbeitung dessen
was da auf Befehl des Kreml täglich
geschieht läuft längst aber sie kämpft
mit ganz eigenen Herausforderungen heute
eröffnet in Den Haag ein neues
internationales strafverfolgungszentrum
das Beweise sammeln und eine Lücke
schließen soll die ist im
internationalen Strafrecht immer noch
gibt Isabel Schäfers mit mehr dazu
die Bombardierung von Krankenhäusern
Angriffe auf Zivilisten Folter
Vergewaltigung mehr als 93.000
mutmaßliche Kriegsverbrechen hat die
ukrainische Staatsanwaltschaft bisher
dokumentiert einige Beschuldigte bereits
vor Gericht gestellt doch gegen den
Ursprung all dieser Kriegsverbrechen den
Angriff auf die Ukraine kann juristisch
bisher wenig getan werden
die Rechenschaft für das Verbrechen der
Aggression ist ein wesentlicher
Bestandteil unserer politischen
rechtlichen und moralischen Agenda wir
alle wissen das Verbrechen der
Aggression ist ein Verbrechen begangen
von Führungspersonen und genau hier ist
eine Schwachstelle im internationalen
Strafrecht das will die westliche
internationale Gemeinschaft nun ändern
in Den Haag wurde heute ein
internationales strafverfolgungszentrum
ins Leben gerufen koordiniert von der EU
Justizbehörde Eurojust das Ziel schon
während des Krieges sollen Beweise
gesammelt werden
wir machen das zum ersten Mal während
ein Konflikt noch läuft noch nie in der
Geschichte hatten wir mehr Beweise für
die Aggression als heute wir sprechen
etwa von Luftaufnahmen abgefangener
Kommunikation Daten von Mobiltelefonen
GPS
Kaffee
GPS der Internationale Strafgerichtshof
sammelt bereits Beweise für einzelne
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine der
Gerichtshof kann aber bisher nicht gegen
den übergeordneten Tatbestand des
Angriffskrieges tätig werden
wir haben erkannt das Gerechtigkeit nur
auf der Grundlage von Partnerschaften
funktionieren kann dies ist der Beginn
eines Prozesses er erfordert weitere
Anstrengungen und Konzentration aber ich
denke er ist bedeutsam nur ein erster
Schritt also um Putin und andere
Führungspersonen im Kreml letztlich
tatsächlich für die Aggression gegen die
Ukraine zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen
bräuchte es neben den Beweisen auch ein
zuständiges Gericht dafür wäre ein ganz
neues Tribunal erforderlich darüber wird
rechtlich und politisch derzeit viel
verhandelt aber mit diesem neuen
strafverfolgungszentrum sagen Sie wir
werden nicht darauf warten wir tun schon
mal das was geht ich glaube das eine der
Aufgaben nicht nur darin bestehen wird
Beweise auszutauschen und zu an
alysieren es geht auch darum eine
strafrechtliche Strategie zu entwickeln
wie ein Gerichtsprozess aufgebaut sein
kann
einig sind sich hier alle Putin muss
bestraft werden aber alle wissen auch
dass wird nicht leicht und das heute war
nur ein Anfang
wir bleiben noch beim Krieg und seinen
Folgen Hanna du hast den
Nachrichtenüberblick ja
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat bei
seinem Besuch in Polen schnelle
Fortschritte beim Aufbau eines
gemeinsamen
panzer-reparaturzentrums für die Ukraine
gefordert die Zeit dränge erklärte
Pistorius nach einem Gespräch mit seinem
Amtskollegen burstak bereits im April
war die Einrichtung des Zentrums
beschlossen worden zum Wunsch Polens die
Stationierung der deutschen Patriot
Flugabwehrsysteme im Land zu verlängern
nach monatelangen Verhandlungen hat sich
die Bundesregierung auf einen Entwurf
für den Haushalt 2024 geeinigt die
Ausgaben sollen auf
445,7 Milliarden Euro sinken damit liegt
die Neuverschuldung bei knapp 16,6
Milliarden und die Schuldenbremse wird
eingehalten im schreit um die Kinder
Grundsicherung hat Bundeskanzler Scholz
nun Familienministerin Paul gebeten
verschiedene Modelle zur Ausgestaltung
zu erarbeiten und einen Ressort
übergreifenden Gesetzentwurf bis Ende
August vorzulegen bisher fordert Pause
für die Kinder Grundsicherung ab 2025
mindestens 12 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
vorgesehen sind als Merkposten aktuell
zwei Milliarden
israel hat im Westjordanland einen der
größten Militäreinsätze der vergangenen
Jahre gestartet ziel sei es
terroristische Infrastruktur zu treffen
dabei griff die israelische Armee die
Stadt Jenny und das angrenzende
Flüchtlingslager aus der Luft an und
marschierte außerdem mit botentruppen
ein mindestens acht Palästinenser wurden
getötet Dutzende verletzt der Einsatz
dauert zur Stunde noch an
in Frankreich App die Gewalt langsam ab
die Polizei meldet deutlich weniger
festgenommene Randalierer als in der den
ersten Tagen nach dem Tod eines
17-jährigen durch eine Polizeikugel
heute Nacht sollen wieder 45.000
Polizisten für Ruhe sorgen als Zeichen
der Solidarität angesichts des Angriffs
auf das Wohnhaus eines Bürgermeisters
gab es heute in zahlreichen Städten
Versammlungen morgen wird sich Präsident
macron mit Bürgermeisterinnen und
Bürgermeisterin beraten deren Städte von
Ausschreitungen betroffen waren
wegen der Krawalle in Frankreich hat das
75 Jubiläum des deutsch-französischen
Instituts heute ohne Präsident macron
stattgefunden Bundespräsident Steinmeier
würde ich das Institut als
außergewöhnliches und visionäres Projekt
auch dank dessen Arbeit sei die
Freundschaft der beiden Länder so tief
verankert Ludwigsburg den Sitz des
Instituts nannte Steinmeier einen
historischen Ort deutsch-französischer
Versöhnung
1962 hatte dort der französische
Präsident de Gaulle seine wegweisende
Rede an die deutsche Jugend gehalten
[Applaus]
das heißt
Kinder eines großen Volkes ja wohl eines
großen Volkes
heute beginnt ein neues Kapitel in der
langen und herausfordernden Geschichte
der Pandemie Bekämpfung es startet der
erste Schadensersatzprozess gegen den
Impfstoffhersteller biontech nur der
Anfang einer ganzen Prozesswelle gegen
alle Hersteller insgesamt rund 300
Verfahren in den kommenden Monaten in
Deutschland
klar ist eines die corona-impfungen
hatten für die allermeisten der 65
Millionen geimpften in Deutschland keine
Komplikationen für einzelne aber eben
schon und die Gerichtsverfahren über
Nebenwirkungen der Impfungen werfen auch
andere Fragen auf etwa nach der Rolle
des Staates der sich verpflichtet hatte
mögliche Entschädigungszahlungen selbst
zu übernehmen sondern Santina berichtet
Katja kann kaum laufen und dann nur
unter Schmerzen letzten Monate hat die
47-Jährige 22 Stunden am Tag liegen zu
Hause verbracht eine akute luftnotrat
bei ihr gleich nach der ersten
kurve-impfung auf da sie als Pflegerin
weiterarbeiten wollte und Ärzte es ihr
auch im fallen ließe sich erneut mit dem
Impfstoff von biontech impfen
am ganzen Körper in den Beinen in der
Wade die Schmerzen die Ohren zu extrem
gewesen ich wollte mir die Beine
abnehmen lassen
ich konnte mit einmal nicht mehr lesen
diagnostiziert wurde bei Katja unter
anderem eine extreme Muskelschwäche
[Musik]
Nesselsucht und Auto Antikörper die sich
gegen ihre eigene Organe richten als
unerwünschte Nebenwirkungen von COBIT
Impfstoffen laut mehreren Ärzten sie
hätten im Hersteller für verantwortlich
im Landgericht Rottweil hat heute der
erste Prozess gegen Bayern ein
58-jähriger Mann der sein rechtes Augen
nicht verloren hat und die Ursache der
bei ontech-impfung sieht fordert 150.000
Euro Schmerzensgeld juristisch ist der
im Hersteller der Gegner doch als damals
die Verträge mit der EU geschlossen
wurden wurde der Pharmahersteller von
jeglicher Haftung befreit
es ist halt schade wenn man auch sieht
was für ein riesen Freibrief ja diese
Pharma-Konzerne bekommen haben und mit
welchem kleinen Risiko oder so gut wie
gar keinem einem das vermittelt wurde es
gebe faktisch zwei juristische Gegner
sagt seinen Anwalt wenn hier verloren
wird wird am Ende eben die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland das heißt der
Steuerzahler alle Kosten übernehmen das
heißt hier ist der Staat nicht in eine
neutralen Rolle wir fordern letztendlich
für ihn die Solidarität von der damals
so viel gesprochen worden ist für
Betroffene wie liebt man es wird es
schwer zu belegen dass die Impfung den
Schaden verursacht hat und wenn dem im
Hersteller keine Fehler nachgewiesen
werden können stehen die Chancen für
Kläger ohnehin schlecht das gilt auch
wenn einzelne krasse im Schäden
auftreten zumindest solange insgesamt
der Nutzen der Impfung überwiegt und
genau davon gehen bislang Behörden und
Gerichte aus versteht bunt und Länder
hatten die kobit Impfkampagne
unterstützt und etwa durch zweijährige
und maskenpflicht auch im Drucker bleibt
Rechtsanwältin Jessica Hamed dann muss
ich natürlich erst recht sicherstellen
dass in dem Fall wo sich jemand der sich
ja quasi für die Allgemeinheit aufopfert
dass der dann entschädigt wird falls es
zum Schaden kommt das wäre das Mindeste
was jetzt vom Staat erfolgen muss dass
er sagt wir entschädigen auf dem Niveau
es reicht die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
eben im Schaden entstanden ist doch die
Hürden für staatliche Entschädigungen
sind hoch von knapp 8000 Anträgen wurden
bislang 325 anerkannt fast 2500
abgelehnt vor Gericht sind rund 300
Klagen gegen kobit im Hersteller
anhängig Bayer und Heck hält alle
bisherigen gegen ihn für unbegründet
nach dem Stand der Wissenschaft und im
Austausch mit den zuständigen Behörden
wurde bis dato kein Impfstoff assoziiert
dazu Zusammenhang festgestellt
auch Katjas Antrag auf Entschädigung
wurde vom Land abgelehnt gegen Bayern
und der klagen können Sie sich nicht
leisten sagt sie es sei aber wohl
ohnehin aussichtslos
so und jetzt in der Sendung noch mal
Johanna
angesichts explodierender Energiepreise
und rekordinflationen hat die
Bundesregierung in den vergangenen
Monaten ja gleich mehrere
entlastungspakete geschnürt was diese
tatsächlich gebracht haben das zeigt
jetzt eine neue Studie des Instituts der
deutschen Wirtschaft valer in Frankfurt
zu welchem Ergebnis kommt die
Untersuchung ja sie kommt zu dem Schluss
dass der Staat sein Ziel erreicht hat
einen Großteil der Mehrbelastungen
auszugleichen 28 Maßnahmen waren es
insgesamt für rund 240 Milliarden Euro
darunter Preis Bremsen für Strom und Gas
und eben auch der Tankrabatt Menschen
mit geringem Einkommen haben der Studie
zufolge besonders von den staatlichen
Hilfen profitiert weniger erhalten dem
nach kinderlose Normalverdiener
und dann gab es heute auf dem
Frankfurter Börsenparkett auch noch
Grund zum Feiern warum genau der DAX ist
35 Jahre alt geworden ein bisschen wurde
gefeiert das Parkett etwas belebter als
sonst aber nicht so vergleichen mit
seinem Geburtsjahr da war was los auf
dem Parketten 1988 als der DAX an den
Start ging aber so richtig ist der Funke
bei den Deutschen nie übergesprungen
viele sind immer noch aktienmuffel dabei
hätte man ein dickes Plus kassieren
können wer von Anfang an dabei gewesen
ist hätte seinen Einsatz von damals mehr
als vor 15facht heute hat der DAX ein
bisschen schlapp gemacht mit einem
kleinen minus damit liegt der aber keine
300 Punkte unter dem Allzeithoch na wenn
das kein Grund zum Feiern ist
vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
die Fußball-Legende Horst Dieter Höttges
ist tot der ehemalige Nationalspieler
und Bremer Verteidiger starb im Alter
von 79 Jahren
wurde im Nationaltrikot 1972
Europameister und zwei Jahre später bei
der Heim WM Weltmeister auf dem Platz
schonte er weder sich noch seine Gegner
er war für seine robuste Spielweise in
der Abwehr gefürchtet sein Spitzname
Eisenfuß
bei der Tour de France haben die Fahrer
nach dem Start im spanischen Baskenland
heute auf der dritten Etappe Frankreich
erreicht erster im Ziel von bion wurde
der Belgier Jasper Philipsen ganz knapp
dahinter der deutsche Phil Bauhaus
eingeschlossenes Feld auf den ersten
Kilometern in Frankreich keiner wagt
noch einen Ausreißversuch bion erlebt
den erwarteten Massensprint auf der
Innenseite schiebt sich der Belgier
Jasper Philips sind vor und holt sich
nach zwei Erfolgen im Vorjahr seinen
dritten Etappen Sieg eine schnellere
Schlussphase jedoch zeigt den weißen
Trikot viel Bauhaus bei seiner ersten
urteilnahme gleich ein zweiter Rang für
den 30-jährigen Mann aus Bocholt
natürlich gutes Ergebnis
drüber freuen aber
wenn man so nah dran ist dass man
natürlich auch ein bisschen enttäuscht
der Brite Adams bleibt auch nach der
dritten Etappe im gelben Trikot des
gesamtbesten
so kleiner Service Hinweis an dieser
Stelle wir sind bereits wieder näher am
kommenden Weihnachtsfest dran als das
Vergangene zurück liegt wie wir heizen
werden in diesem Land und Klima schonend
für diese Welt ist ja bereits bestimmen
das Thema des Sommers heute hat die
finale Fassung des heizungsgesetzes
tatsächlich den Bundestag erreicht im
Vogtland in Sachsen gucken sie derweil
fasziniert unter die Erde und voller
Hoffnung auf den Geysir von geilsdorf
Stefan Kirch
seit Urzeiten sprudeln geheimnisvolle
Quellen im Dunkelwald so nannten die
Menschen das Erzgebirge als sie vom Erz
im Gebirge noch nichts wussten was sie
kannten die heißen Quellen in den [__]
Heilquellen um sie entstehen ganze
Städte reiche Kurbäder bis heute eine
ähnlich ruhmreiche Zukunft könnte auch
diese Quelle haben kein Kurbad zwar aber
möglicherweise ein Geothermie-Kraftwerk
seit Bergleute in den 60er Jahren hier
geboren haben sprudelt ein kleiner
Geysir ununterbrochen damals spuckte das
Bohrloch heißes Wasser über die
Bergleute 50 m hoch war die Fontäne
jetzt kam der Landrat des Erzgebirges
auf die naheliegende Idee mit dem heißen
Wasser Wohnungen zu heizen das würde
sich für 80.000 Haushalte rechnen und
nicht nur für die Stadtwerke etc die mit
ins Boot holen wollen dann werden ja
auch sehen dass man dort wie eine
Windkraftanlage wie eine BH Anlage
wenn die wenn die Forschung
abgeschlossen ist und die ist positiv
denke ich wird es mehrere Leute geben
die hier mit ihr Geld verdienen wollen
auch ab sofort können sich
Wissenschaftler darum ob das Wasser aus
der Tiefe den Aufwand auch lohnt
wie lange das reicht kann man heute noch
nicht sagen aber wir sind auf die Frage
vorbereitet und wären auch versuchen die
Fragen zu beantworten 50 Jahre ist aber
eine Aussage von der Industrie 50 Jahre
hoffentlich reichts über eine noch zu
bauen der Leitung soll das Wasser von
der Quelle zum Beispiel in die Stadt
Plauen gelangen wenn das möglich ist
technisch und wirtschaftlich machbar ist
er damit mit der Wärme wir nehmen die ab
und verteilen die im System in Plauen
gibt es bereits ein gut ausgebautes
Fernwärmenetz das ist das eine das
andere die Häuser müssen saniert und
gedämmt werden nur so ist es sinnvoll
das heiße Wasser des Geysirs über so
weite Strecken hierher zu pumpen und
auch eine größere Effizienz zu erreichen
ist es für uns natürlich auch wichtig
dass natürlich die die Sanierung der
sanierungswille natürlich auch einsetzt
bei den Kunden insgesamt im Erzgebirge
mögen sie zwar Windräder nicht besonders
aber gegen Geothermie hat hier keiner
was wir sind es im gesamten Erzgebirge
aber auch im Vogtland dass die Bergbau
Vergangenheit dieser Region mit dazu
beiträgt für einen Verständnis für
Eingriffe in den Untergrund und auch für
akzeptanzt dieses Wasser ist 30.000
Jahre alt es kommt aus einer Tiefe von
etwa 40 km der Druck ist so gewaltig
dass die Quelle bis heute gezähmt werden
muss in etwa fünf bis zehn Jahren
könnten ihr diese Fesseln abgenommen
werden
Vorbild ist natürlich Island wo sie bis
vor 90 Jahren die Häuser auch noch mit
Holz oder Kohle heizten mittlerweile
leiten sie ihr heißes geysirwasser dafür
um und sagen wenn man eines Tagesenergie
per Satellit in die Welt verkaufen kann
dann ist das Paradies Island perfekt
dann können wir uns zurücklehnen und nur
noch gute Bücher schreiben und lesen
das war unser heute journal an diesem
Montag haben wir heute oder ja und
später gibt es noch unser heute journal
Update mit Gundula Gause gegen 23:40 Uhr
vom gesamten Team ein angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter es bleibt
weiterhin unbeständig mit Schauern und
Gewittern und hier auf dem Regen Film
sehen wir wie zum Beispiel in der Nacht
hier Schauer und Gewitter aufziehen die
verlagern sich allmählich ostwärts und
auch im Süden gibt es regen ja und dann
morgen zum Abend und in der Nacht auf
Mittwoch geht's dann ruppiger zu von
Westen herkommen heftige Schauer und
Gewitter ins Land aber erstmal schauen
wir in die kommende Nacht und da gibt es
im Norden schon Schauer und Gewitter
teilweise mit viel Wind und durchaus
auch stark kriegen ganz im Süden regnet
es auch dazwischen ist es aufgelockert
und trocken bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von 9 Grad ganz im Westen und 15 Grad am
Oberrhein morgen dann weitere Schauer
und Gewitter im Norden die verdichten
sich dann am Nachmittag die Wolken und
dann gibt's neue Schauer und auch
Gewitter im Süden ebenfalls mit Blitz
und Donner dazwischen sonnige Abschnitte
die Temperaturen dazu steigen bis auf 27
Grad im Südwesten also am wärmsten aber
häufig liegen wir um die 25 Grad Marke
am kühlsten ist es noch Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein bei 18 Grad ja oder
Mittwoch kommt ein neues Tief mit neuen
Schauern und Gewittern und die können
durchaus unwetterartig sein mit
Starkregen Hagel und Sturmböen das bei
Temperaturen von 18 bis 26 Grad ja und
am Donnerstag beruhigt es sich Freitag
wird es heiß bei Temperaturen bis 31°,
damit ein schöner Abend